[Musique]
jamais nous n'avons autant la veine ou
moins que depuis la mi mars
une consigne de santé publique qui
moussent les ventes d savonnerie
artisanale l'entreprise pousser à des
toiles de percer reçoit quatre fois plus
de commandes en ligne depuis le début de
la pandémie et un explosion sur la
boutique en année un exemple un jeu du
soir à 18h aller jusqu'au samedi 13 ans
on avait un volume de 244 comment la
savonnière qui confectionne ses produits
à partir de lait d'ânesse ne cesse de
conquérir de nouveaux clients
selon elle les gens se tournent vers des
savons plus doux et hydratant pour
minimiser les effets des lavages
fréquents sur la peau c'est ça que ça se
compare pas un savon de fabrication
artisanale avec un savon du commerce ou
autres produits de soins corporels et on
travaille avec des princes des vrais
ingrédients
[Musique]
au quai des bulles de kamouraska la
demande en ligne tels que l'atelier
fournit désormais sept jours sur sept
pour confectionner les savons et
préparer les envois postaux
les ventes en ligne ont explosé l'on
parle d'une augmentation de près de 750
pour ça la savonnière explique cette
hausse par une prise de conscience
collective concernant l'achat local ya
tout de l'engouement la du panier bleus
achat local ça aussi ça fait une grosse
différence
on a une grosse aux deux nouveaux
clients mais l'essor de l'achat en ligne
sera t-il suffisant pour contrebalancer
une diminution probable des ventes en
boutique
à quelques semaines d'une saison
touristique incertaine la question
demeure entière
la saison estivale dans nos boutiques ça
correspond quand même à 45 50 % de nos
revenus annuels dont qu'habituellement
l'été nos boutiques sont au bond et ça
fait la file je pense que la saison va
être quand même bonne très courte parce
que absolument en septembre mono et les
gens qui viennent d'ailleurs donc
doucement de des européens et tous les
savonnières peuvent au moins compter sur
une certitude le lavage des mains n'est
pas une habitude qu'on est sur le point
de délester
[Musique]
ici la belle la rose radio canada
carleton sur mer